according to espn a woman is a he
a she and a them rank choice voting is
now systemically racist
and ibrahim hindi tries and fails to
explain how he's not actually a racist
i'm bench prayer this is the bench
bureau show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like big tech and the government
spying on you visit expressvpn.com
ben speaking of which a few decades ago
private citizens we used to be largely
that
private and then the interwebs happened
the interwebs are great but here's the
problem
people can monitor what you are doing
online we're talking about hackers we're
talking about the government we're
talking about
big tech well why exactly would you want
anybody crawling through
all of your data creating a permanent
public record for you
having a private life exposed for others
to see was one something only
celebrities worried about but now
because everybody is online everybody
has to worry about it unless they use
express
vpn did you know there are hundreds of
data brokers out there their sole
business is to buy and sell your data
the worst part they don't have to tell
you who they're selling into or get your
consent
one of these data points is your ip
address data harvesters use that ip
to uniquely identify you and your
location both expressvpn
my connection gets re-routed through an
encrypted server my ip address is masked
every time i turn expressvpn on i'm
given a random ip address shared by
other
expressvpn customers which makes it a
lot more difficult for third parties to
identify me and harvest my data and it's
super easy to use basically install it
with one click and then with another
click
it is now active it's that simple so if
like me you believe your data is your
business secure yourself with the number
one rated vpn on the market visit
expressvpn.com
and get three extra months for free
that's expr essvpn.com
go to expressvpn.com ben to learn more
okay so
yesterday i was browsing these world of
sports and i came across an article
that was so astonishing in its stupidity
and confusion that it forcibly struck me
i mean it really was
the single worst piece of writing i have
ever seen and the reason it was the
single worst piece of writing
i've ever seen is because it is utterly
incoherent i want to read it to you
it's about a person named lucia
clarendon the wnba's first openly
non-binary and transgender player okay
it's by a person
named katie barnes okay here is the p's
i'm gonna read the first three
paragraphs and you will immediately
not understand anything okay this is a
thing that a human wrote
lacia clarendon wrapped their hand
around the back of a fussy newborn
looking up at them
in the maternity recovery room at a bay
area hospital a nurse had just shown
lacia how to cradle the baby in a
football hold
unless she arrested the soft skin of the
baby's back against her
own left forearm and held the baby's
head in her hand
okay so at the beginning you're like
okay so we were talking about non-binary
person who wants to be called them
within the same paragraph this person is
now being called her
but wait baby c they them because the
baby doesn't have a gender either okay
we're now working in this bizarre
universe in which a baby comes out we
know whether it's a boy or a girl but we
pretend we don't know if it's a boy or
girl because literally you can change
your gender up to the day you die
and then after you die and after your
body decays and all that's left is your
bone structure scientists a thousand
years from now can also know whether
you're a boy or a girl in any case
they them baby c they them and gurgled
and squirmed at lacie's touch
legia accepted shampoo from the nurse
silently wondering if it would be
appropriate
for black hair with her right hand she
gently rubbed her fingers through the
silky curls of baby c's full head of
hair
so so far it's a woman right a woman who
identifies as they them that's what you
can
get from the first couple paragraphs
here's where things take a sideways turn
it was december 21st 2020 babysie's
birthday and first wash day
leshia's wife jessica she her had just
given birth to baby c by caesarean
section
after a 29 hour labor after carrying the
baby for just over 41 weeks
as jessica recovered leshia found
himself alone
with his first child i know what you're
thinking
what he never expected to have these
first moments alone with baby c
lacia and jessica had planned for a
vaginal birth and for these moments
to be shared exhausted and weak jessica
joined leicester and baby in the
recovery room 30 minutes later
leshia held the baby up to jessica's
chest to assist with babysit's first
meal
as jessica drifted off lacia placed
babysitte back in the hospital bassinet
he removed his shirt and sat down latia
picked the baby back up
cradling bbc against their chest
um so in the first several paragraphs of
this piece we now learn
that lacia clarendon is referred to as
wait for it
they them her
she he and him
now this makes a mockery of language
right you have no id you you now have
less information
about lacia clarendon than you did at
the beginning of these you don't know
anything about lacia clarendon if you
just read this piece if you're an alien
from outer space or a normal english
speaker
either of the two and you read this
piece you would not know whether lacia
clarendon
is a boy or a girl or anything else
it makes no sense it's deliberate
confusion it's deliberate confusion
and if you mention that it's deliberate
confusion then you are called the bigot
if you point out that this is absolutely
nonsensical
that the ex the terms he and she
and they have quite specific meanings in
english he refers to males she refers to
females and they generally firs refers
to the plural
unless it is a they at the end of a
sentence and it is referring back to a
she or he antecedent typically
but here you have all of these terms
being used for one person
the only purpose here is to convey less
information with language
it is to isolate you more it's to make
you feel more confused for the sexual
revolutionary left confusion is the
point
boys and girls they're not supposed to
mean anything they're all social
constructs
unless sexual orientation is invoked in
which case it's not a social construct
it's biological
reality but also you can shape your
sexual orientation and choose it over
time
it can be bisexual or pansexual or gay
or lesbian or straight
at any time you can identify as any of
those things
but they are both biologically immutable
and also social constructions
according to the radical left and we
have now entered the world of michel
foucault in which language is just power
the arbitrary shifts in language are
designed to promote power
just as in an authoritarian governmental
system
arbitrary shifts of the rules that
you're supposed to know and you get
punished if you find yourself in breach
of those rules they are designed to
simply
re-enshrine and reinforce the power of
the system over you
radical shifts in language where words
suddenly don't mean what they meant five
seconds ago
and where if you use the word in its
traditional sense you have now crossed
some invisible line you become a bigot
this is a way for the social left to
rule your life it is a way for the
social left
to out you to treat you as a bigot i
have a new book coming out
called the authoritarian moment and one
of the things that i point out in the
authoritarian moment
is that this power game has now
infiltrated
virtually every institution of our
society to even point this out puts you
at risk of censorship from
the big tech companies even point this
out makes you
a person who shouldn't be welcomed into
play conversation
we now identify each other as members of
the ruling class and there is a ruling
class in the united states the way that
you are identified is a member of the
ruling class
the people who deserve to rule is you
put pronouns in your profile if you've
got pronouns in your twitter profile is
not an indicator that there was any
confusion about who you were we all know
who you were because we have eyes and we
have ears and we have
minds right we can identify people based
on objective characteristics
the whole purpose of putting pronoun in
your profile is not even to demonstrate
solidarity because you've demonstrated
nothing
right we don't really know anything
about your politics simply based on what
pronouns apply to you
all it is a way of signaling that you
speak the vocabulary that you speak woke
it's a socially authoritarian method of
ostracizing people
who think in terms of traditional
objective metrics
now how stupid is this particular espn
story i use this as an example because
this is the cover story espn magazine by
the way okay
so the reason i use this is because not
only is this supremely confusing and
designed to be confusing
there's an editor's note attached the
editor's note says this quote
lacia clarendon who identifies as
transgender and non-binary
again if you are non-binary meaning you
don't actually have a gender how are you
transgender
are you a woman who became a man are you
a woman who became nothing
are you a woman who became a genderless
widget like what exactly are you
the terms transgender and transgender
suggests that you change your gender
from one to the other typically
non-binary means you don't identify as
any gender
so these two terms should be somewhat
mutually exclusive they're not right
leishia clarendon who identifies as
transgender and non-binary
uses he him she her and they them
pronouns interchangeably
we do so throughout this piece we also
introduce the preferred pronouns for
others who appear in this story
and for whom pronouns are used okay so
instead of the editors doing what
editors typically do which is
make sure that language conveys
information this is what editors and
writers are designed to do
right there there's a post-modern
discourse in literature in which
language is not supposed to convey
information
it is instead supposed to enshrine
certain moods it's supposed to generate
certain feelings but
typically the purpose of language is to
convey information
this is true in the animal kingdom as
well right whether it's clicks and
chirps from animals or whether it is the
human voice
the goal is generally to convey more
information
except now now the goal is to convey
less information because the true idea
is to elicit from you
whether you object to this and thus can
be ostracized safely
from the membership in the new ruling
class
and this is nothing new and there's an
article we talked about on the show way
back in april
in the new york times called a guide to
neo pronouns so you're confused by all
this we'll let the new york times
guide you through all of this you will
be more confused by the end
than you were at the beginning according
to the new york times
non-binary pronouns have become
widespread a 2019 pew research study
found already that one in five americans
knew someone who uses non-binary
pronouns
and then there are neo pronouns a
neopronoun can be a word created to
serve as pronoun
without expressing gender like g and jur
a neopronoun can also be
a so-called noun self pronoun in which a
pre-existing word
is drafted into use as a pronoun noun
self-pronouns can refer to animals
so your pronoun can be bun bun self and
kitten
kitten self others refer to fantasy
characters vamp
vamp self prin says princess self
they fair fair self or even just common
slang like
in it in its in itself
so is this for real says the new york
times yes and
around any leading edge behavior online
trolling hijinks and bad faith collide
indistinctly for those unfamiliar with
the culture surrounding the
pronouns right now it's likely
impossible to distinguish between what's
playful
what's deeply meaningful and what's
people being mean
many neo-pronoun users are dead serious
and are also part of online communities
that are quick to react swiftly
to offenses a popular twitch streamer
who goes by andyvmg recently apologized
after tweet jokingly tweeting that her
pronouns were bad af
which led many neo-pronoun users to
accuse her of transphobic invalidation
of their identities
andyvmg wrote on twitter it wasn't meant
to mock people who use neopronouns
however i've since educated myself on
the matter and spoken to people who use
neopronouns and i see
why what i said was hurtful
okay now again the idea here that these
neo pronouns kitten kits himself express
just the same amount of information
as a person saying that the person a
biological woman is both
he and she and them precisely nothing
the only thing that it expresses is a
person who
is either unable or unwilling to
identify with reality
that's all but the whole point is that
you too are now supposed to be drafted
into this movement
to normalize delusion you're supposed to
be drafted into this movement
to normalize delusion and this this
notion
that personal identity that how i
identify must be reflected by the
society at large and if you refuse
to go along with my moral vision of
society if you
refuse to clap and cheer along you have
denied me
my identity you have undermined me as a
human being
and corporations because so many
corporations are in the business of
catering
to clientele right this is what
corporations do corporations are going
to sell you what you want to buy well
right now what people want to buy is a
vision of themselves
and that vision of themselves can be
anything and so corporations
are simply going to celebrate whatever
you believe
you are in order to make money right so
this has led people on the right to say
capitalism is the problem okay
capitalism is not the problem capitalism
is just not designed
to be the moral imprimature okay
capitalism is the greatest system
for the distribution and increase in
wealth and human history
without a doubt but capitalism is not
inherently tied
the system itself is not inherently tied
to anything beyond provision of services
and products to people who want them
and so if you are a business and you are
seeking to cater to people and those
people have immoral wants capitalism
will serve those wants
the same way that would serve somebody
who has a moral want
in other words the lack that we are
seeing in american society right now is
not the result of economics
the lack that we are seeing in american
society right now is a result
of lack of a moral basis a moral
foundational grounding in reality
the reality that we are embodied human
beings we are not just a free-floating
spirit
inside a meatball we are actually an
embodied
thing which means that our biology and
our soul are connected
and that means that we cannot ignore our
biology or treat our biology as though
it were our enemy
but that's precisely what the left seeks
to do the left not only seeks to
treat our biology as an enemy the left
seeks to treat you as an enemy
if you even notice the fact that
objective facts which allow us to have
conversations with one another by the
way
that if objective facts exist and you
acknowledge the existence of these
objective facts
you are now engaged in an act of bigotry
right because i'm denying your identity
subjectivism now rules of the day
and anybody who insists on objective
uses of language
that we can share because there has to
be a term that means something in order
for us to both use it and understand one
another
if you insist on that you're now engaged
in an act of bigotry
all of this is a power game all of this
is a power game
the the confusion the meaninglessness
that is the point
because if you can make everybody
confused and then if you can use that
confusion
in order to instill in everybody else
the idea that if you refuse to acquiesce
to the confusion
this makes you the bad guy well then you
are just as arbitrary
in your use of power as most
authoritarians are and we have a set of
cultural authoritarians
who are who are joining us in the guise
of tolerance and acceptance which is not
what this is
okay we'll get some more of this in just
one second first
let's talk about the fact that if you're
an adult
you have to take care of business and if
you want to take care of business that
means that you need the insurance that
you need right i mean
everybody needs insurance right you need
life insurance you need home insurance
and you need auto insurance well here's
the thing
policy gene is a free and easy way to
check if you could be saving cash on
what you're paying
for home and auto insurance are your
home and auto policies almost up for
renewal let policy genius look for a
lower rate for you
policy genius makes it easy to compare
home and auto insurance in one place
they can help you find home and auto
coverage similar to what you have now
but at a lower price
they've saved customers an average of 1
250 per year over what they were paying
for home and auto insurance
their team will handle the paperwork to
set up your new policy or switch over to
current one
getting started is easy first you head
on over to policygenius.com
shapiro home and you answer a few quick
questions about yourself in your
property and then policy genius takes it
from there they'll help compare rates
from america's top insurers from
progressive to allstate and help you
find your lowest quotes
the policy genius team will look for
ways to save you more including bundling
your home and auto policies and if they
find a better rate than what you're
paying now they will switch you over
for free there's a reason they have an
excellent rating on trustpilot so right
now
get your home and auto insurance ironed
out head on over to policygenius.com
shapiro home get started right now the
adult thing to do is to insure yourself
how you need to be insured
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it is nice and quite important
to get it right okay so there is a
certain zero-sum game between
subjectivism and objectivism
right between objectivity and subjective
self-interpretation
if people who believe that subjectivity
ought to rule the day
when objective language loses if
objective language loses we can't have a
conversation with one another because
the minute you use a term
and then i use the exact same term in
its traditional sense
and you claim now this is bigotry
basically what you're saying is
it's not possible for any two human
beings to understand each other
and this is how the sexual left is part
of the general radical left
because the racial left says the same
thing the racial left says that there's
a certain racial essentialism where
black people and white people cannot
understand black people
and thus you can't have a an honest to
god
open conversation about the
decision-making that leads to success in
a society because we can't understand
each other's experiences
or each other's identities and this is
being reinforced by every major force in
our society right now
particularly our cultural forces and
cultural forces by the way in a free
society like the united states or at
least a fairly free society with regard
to government
cultural forces bleed upward into
politics and we've always said that
culture is upstream of politics and that
is exactly right right usually the law
follows the culture the culture
has decided to to
validate the notion that subjectivity
ought to rule
and then the law which is supposed to be
an objective tool right once the law
becomes subjective it really is
authoritarian
once once the law is just subjectively
interpreted to go after particular
people that is the definition of
authoritarianism
once it bleeds up into the law you got a
real problem on your hands and that's
exactly what has been happening
and this is how you end up with for
example situations
like we have apparently edna an aquatic
center
in of all places pella iowa according to
breitbart.com the pella aquatic center
in pella iowa has confirmed to a
newspaper it allowed a teenage girl to
go topless
and use the men's restroom and locker
room because she said she identified
as a man according to the iowa standard
she shared the facility with boys and
men of all ages
the incident happens on june 20th june
16th according to two people at the
aquatic center the incident did indeed
happen the aquatic
center policy allows it to happen the
assistant manager told the iowa standard
the policy says anyone can wear the
clothing necessary
in line with their gender identity
rather than biological sex
the police policy is set by the city
council according to the aquatic
center's assistant manager
in addition to concerns for the young
children exposed to this as well as the
men and boys
a resident said it's dangerous for the
young minor girl to expose herself
which of course is true apparently this
isn't the only incident
so this sort of stuff is bleeding over
into policy we saw a video emerge
from a spa in los angeles recently in
which a black woman
is complaining at the counter because
apparently there is a biological man who
is walking around
in the women's section of the spa with
his junk hanging out
and the spa said no no he's just
identifying as what he identifies as we
have no rules
on this sort of thing objective reality
is to be put aside and now this has been
shrined
in in federal law they have justice
gorsuch idiotically ruling in bostock
that the civil rights act of 1964 was
meant
to protect men who say they are women in
the same way that the law protects women
which is of course incredibly silly so
you've got the law pushing it
you have culture pushing it
by the way the insulting nature of this
to women is truly amazing
right so apparently a transgender woman
has now taken
the state miss usa crown in nevada
right and basically this is a tribute to
the surgeons because let's
let's face it when it comes to miss usa
contests which are beauty contests which
are supposed to have presumably some
sort of non-subjective beauty standards
in order for a biological man to win a
miss usa contest that person would have
had to have tremendous hormone treatment
and surgery it wouldn't just be like
in a normal biological man without
surgery and hormone treatment walking
into this usa contest
and winning the contest and so so what
this really speaks to is stereotypical
beliefs about female beauty which i
thought the left opposed until five
seconds ago but apparently the left is
very into it right now
here is the first transgender miss
nevada cataluna enriquez a biological
man
explaining the breakthrough nature of
this which again is
less attribute to tolerance than it is a
tribute to how
surgeons and and doctors can treat
people and make them look like members
of the opposite sex without actually
changing their underlying biology it's
amazing because it's pride month and
it's the 52nd anniversary of stonewall
so
it's a special moment for my community
i'm the first trans woman
and a trans woman of color
and it's time that our voices are heard
when i was young i i said that one day i
hope to see someone
like me on stage and miss usa and
it just happened to be i was the person
that i needed
okay so all of culture is pushing the
idea that men can be women
and in fact the best women as it turns
out
and it's pushed you know in every arena
of our society and we're supposed to
celebrate
all of this as though this is a some
sort of societal breakthrough
that pretending men can be women in that
terms have no meaning that all this is a
societal breakthrough and what it leads
to
in the end is a lot of suffering
particularly directed to children
and there's a piece in daily wire today
by amanda presta giacomo
talking about a woman in australia who's
now writing that her gender confused
daughter is going through early
menopause early menopause and she's
quote so proud of him
and we have 15 year olds who are being
treated with heavy doses
of of testosterone to stop them from
having periods and to go through early
menopause to prepare them for
life-altering surgery when we have not
actually checked out the longitudinal
effects
of this stuff in any serious way there
are consequences to this but again
the personal is political the personal
is is
the the personal is political what you
do in your own personal life is now
considered to be what the law should be
for everybody else
and again what that's really designed to
do is say that if you have any standards
for your own children if you have any
standards for meaning in society
if you go to church if you simply
believe in natural law
all of this makes you the actual target
okay in just one second we're gonna get
to the situation
in uh in new york which is quite
hilarious we'll get to that in a second
first i do want to talk to you
about how this sort of radical leftism
with regard to subjectivity also
applies to rays right so when it comes
to the radical left on race again the
confusion is the point
you're not supposed to have any
objective standards for how we measure
people's performance if you use
objective standards for how to measure
people's performance this is now
considered racist in the same way that
it is considered sexist now
if you say objectively speaking there's
a man and there's a woman in there not
the same thing
if you point that out this is bad with
regard to sex
because again the confusion is the point
you set up all these varying standards
that don't have any consistent basis for
them and then you use them as a club
against everybody that you don't like
right who disagrees with you and
actually holds to objective standards
the same thing holds true on race and
this leads to some incredibly racist
places
because basically what you have is the
racial radicals in our society which is
increasingly taken over the entire
democratic party
you have them basically saying that any
objective metric used with regard to
performance
is inevitably going to consign black
people to doom
which is a pretty racist idea that the
works in the races have a lot in common
they both seem to believe in the
inferiority of black people
or their inability to perform at the
same levels as white people which is
fairly incredible and many of them will
just acknowledge this openly
for example there's a video that went
viral yesterday the new york k-12
educator
suggesting that black students do not
think analytically
black people we are relational people we
are people of context
like it's very western and european to
to
dissect and analyze and take apart
things
whereas afrocentric schooling or
afro-centric spirituality or african
epistemology or ways of knowing
everything is connected so this is why
education is not working for so many
students of color because we are
context-driven people
okay so the person speaking right there
by the way is maria aquinale phd
the founder and lead education
consultant of a geary learning an
organization
that has helped hundreds of school
leaders and organizations embrace
strategize and enact positive change
also this person apparently
teaches as an injunction assistant
professor at columbia university
okay that's sort of racism that she's
speaking there in which she basically
says that black people think
relationally
but black people do not think in terms
of analytic skill
i mean that's an astonishing statement
but it goes back to the basic
deconstructionist idea
which lies behind both the sexual
radical policies and the and the
racially radical policies
which is that objective metrics and
objective abilities to
adjudicate what goes on in the world all
of any attempt to be objective about the
world that surrounds you
what that really is is your own western
bias
right it is it is how you value
objectivity that is the problem because
maybe we should just
not value objectivity it's not that
facts aren't facts facts can be facts
it's that
you think facts are important facts
aren't important that's a cultural
hallmark
of whiteness it's a cultural hallmark of
of
western imperialist culture this is why
you had that
exhibit in the national museum of
african american history over the
smithsonian
specifically saying that things like
timeliness and hard work were white
behaviors which is insane
anytime anybody tells you that
merit-based activities
are racist you should immediately begin
to wonder
whether they are attempting to divide
and use power
because that that really is what they
are attempting to do one of the people
who does this the most is ibra max
kennedy of course ever max kennedy
basically says that if you use anything
like objectivity
if you ever suggest that individually
based rights
are the fundamental basis for a free
society or that people ought to be
treated
equally under the law without regard to
their race this makes you a racist so he
was asked about his own racism
by joy reid who of course is is fully in
line with the iberomex kennedy playbook
kenny is one of the great grifters of
our time uh he's a sloppy thinker to say
that he's a thinker i think is is an
insult to thinkers he's an incredibly
sloppy thinker
his his book how to be an anti-racist is
one of the great racist tomes in modern
american history
is a person who is a fascist i mean he
has openly suggested there ought to be a
department of anti-racism at the federal
government level
unelected and their job would be to
strike down any state federal or local
policy
that ends with inequality of outcome
okay so here's over max kennedy trying
to explain why what he's saying is not
racist when it
pretty clearly is racist black people
are also dying at the highest rates from
cove in 19.
you know maybe shape they should also
receive
maybe they should also receive vaccine
first maybe we should have a
a a system in which those who have
the those who have the greatest needs
are provided with what they need but
they call that reverse discrimination
they call that discrimination they're
against that
how are we going to create equity and
justice for all
if we're providing the same resources to
middle-income people as we're providing
to billionaires
okay so what if kennedy there is saying
is he's talking specifically about
covert policy
okay what he's saying about covet policy
this just shows the nonsensical nature
of what he
of what he argues first of all he argues
that he's not saying that white people
are racist he's just saying that
complicity in the system makes you a
racist
and also if you're white you're
complicit in the system just by nature
i mean that that really is his argument
but what he's saying about kova there
is is so typical of how we are supposed
to think about objective metrics so
covet 19 policy is what he's talking
about there you'll remember there was a
big debate when it came to tranching out
vaccines
in which many people myself included
said the single
greatest variable that explains covid
and how it affects people is age
if you're older you're much more likely
to die of covet if you're younger you're
much less likely to die of covet
abram candy because he only sees the
world in terms of race he says well if
you're black
you're more likely to die of covet than
if you are white
okay well that is seeing through like
the tertiary
or or you know way down on the list like
the ninth place factor because the
reality is you have a bunch of
complications
that cross streams with rays right you
have age
you have obesity you have underlying
health conditions
if we were to trench out vaccines based
on race as opposed to based on age you
would end up with more dead black people
as we explained at the time
because you'd be ignoring the older
black people in favor of the younger
black people because
black america is demographically younger
than white america
so what you'd end up with is more black
people getting the vaccine but also more
black people dying
ironically okay but iberomex kenny
doesn't care about any of that
because objectivity statistics math
these things are bad these things are
very bad and this is how you end up
with stories over and over in the new
york times in which you
just ignore data and objective metrics
in favor of a softer sense that there is
supposed to be an outcome
right in favor of a subjective sense
that what i want from the world is what
the world must give to me
and the government must be my tool in
making that happen for me so for example
today in the new york times there's an
article about target store closings in
baltimore now the reason that the
targets are closing in baltimore is
pretty obvious
baltimore is a very violent place it has
extremely high levels of shoplifting
there's not a lot
of family income in baltimore the
education system sucks there's a lot of
crime right this
none of these make for a very safe place
to open a target
and every time there's a riot people
loot the target right that is a that is
a
very bad way like target opened these
stores
in order to service the local community
they found that they could not
service the local community profitably
so they closed the stores
instead the new york times suggests that
it must be racism because again to look
at objective metrics
to look at actual complicating factors
would be to undermine the power argument
that they are making it is a power
argument they're making they should have
power over you
and if we have to throw the stats out
the window and object we will do that
here's the new york times when target
announced it was opening a store in
montaumen
a predominantly black neighborhood in
baltimore struggling with crime and
poverty it seemed like a ticket to a
turnaround
and from the start it was a practical
success and a point of community pride
the store which opened in 2008 carried
groceries operated a pharmacy and had a
starbucks cafe
the only one in this part of baltimore's
west side people came from across the
city to shop there helping to soften
the mondalman's area's reputation for
crime and the looting that followed
protests over the 2015 death of
freddie gray who was fatally injured
while in city police custody
as an employer target seemed to cater to
the community's needs making a point of
hiring black men
providing an office in the store for a
social worker to support the staff
elijah cummings was known to shop there
but in february 2018 with almost
no warning or explanation target closed
the store now
you may notice the timeline here right
there this is the new york times saying
this must be it must have been a
profitable magical store right i mean
everything's going great
here's the timeline they opened in 2008.
in 2015 the entire
store was looted in 2018 they closed
apparently it's racism according to the
new york times residents especially
those without cars
lost a convenient place to shop for
quality goods and a marker of the
community's self-worth was suddenly
taken away
well you know what should be a marker of
community self-worth
whether the community makes decisions
capable of supporting a target
whether the community is capable of
working with the police to quash crime
providing a social framework necessary
to ensure that kids go to school and get
educated
and that there are not people looting
the target right
the presence of the target is merely a
symptom the absence of the target is
merely a symptom there are underlying
causes to whether a target locates in a
particular
area but if you point this out then of
course you are
not validating the subjective assessment
of people who live in a particular area
reverend frank lance pastor of mount
lebanon baptist church in mount dallas
says to open a store like targeted an
african-american neighborhood gave this
area legitimacy
when the store closed it was like saying
you are not worthy after all
right it's target's job to validate
people who live in this area
at loss to their own profit it is their
job to validate the subjective sense of
self
self-worth that people hold in a
particular area it is not the job
of people in a particular area to
facilitate an environment in which a
target can stay
you may notice that there are black
communities all over the united states
that have targets
this is not one of them the reason that
this is not one of them is because of
the high crime
areas is it it is because of the
behavior
of members of the community okay but
using the
again it's all about how people react to
you it's not about how you act
okay because if you're going to focus in
on equality of outcome without looking
at the behavior of individuals then what
you are inevitably going to do is
suggest that the system is rigged
against individuals three years later
according to the new york times the
store remains empty its closing still
stings montalman residents and baltimore
officials but granted 15 million dollars
in subsidies to help develop the
property
many national retailers have faced
criticism in the past for failing to
open in black and poor communities
creating food deserts or lack of access
to quality goods again the notion is
that national retailers are responsible
for the food deserts as opposed to
the lack of ability to create a store
that is profitable in particular areas
in montalman target invested in a
struggling area but the outcome was
almost more disheartening
the company ultimately decided that
despite its social goals the store
wasn't
financially successful enough to keep
open the closing is a sobering reminder
of the realities of capitalism ah
you see it's capitalism that is to blame
always always in a moment when
corporations are making promises to
support black americans
saying their commitment to racial equity
is stronger than ever
it can't be underlying behavior of
people in a community that make
these stores not profitable is
capitalism itself that is the problem
it is all a power game it's a power game
and that is uh truly unpleasant for the
future of the united states
there's another article in the new york
times today all about this by a person
named samuel gedichow
he graduated from 2020 from oakland
technical high school in california this
in the new york times
and he's the 2019 oakland youth poet
laureate
and apparently he uh he talks about
being a valedictorian in oakland and how
the
at a particular school there are not a
lot of black valedictorians
he says he's talking about some black
valedictorians
and he talks about how it took 106 years
for oakland tech to award
the honor of valedictorian to a black
male student okay and that valedictorian
who was a person by the name of ahmed
muhammad
he said why me i don't know but for all
those who didn't get to maximize their
potential for all those who have the
ability but lack the opportunity i owe
it to them to appreciate this history
made by the people who put me in this
position
we owe it to them to make sure that
while i may be the first young black man
to be our school's valedictorian i won't
be the last okay all of that is fine
but then this person writing in the new
york times says we owe it to them to be
more dedicated to dismantling racism
then to congratulating them for being
among the few to thrive despite it
that requires an examination of the
structures that helped us thrive but
weren't
available to others okay but we're not
actually going to look at the structures
that help these people to thrive
we're not going to look at two-parent
families for example we're not going to
look at charter schools
instead we're going to suggest that
schools that are disproportionately
asian and white because they have
entrance exams and not enough black
students unfortunately are performing
well in the interest exams it's because
they're racist
of course of course subjectivity
in public policy and in social policy
subjectivity
are the hallmark of authoritarian
thinking alrighty coming up
we are going to be getting to gwenberry
who continues to be at the top
of the news plus we'll get to the new
york mayoral race because this is truly
an astonishing
story from from the new york mayoral
race first let us talk for a second
about what your kids are watching and
learning okay disney plus
these days is just pushing left wing
propaganda that's all they do apparently
on disney plus it's
it's amazing like i won't i have disney
plus i will not let my kids
watch disney plaza unless i am picking
the specific show and typically it's an
old movie
okay that is not the case with prageru
prageru has launched a massive new k-12
education program thousands of educators
and parents have already signed up
check it out at prageru.com forward
slash kids
prageru has tons of free kids shows
books magazines with the pro-american
values that aren't being taught in
schools or most kids shows
the prageru website has everything you
need to get your young family through
what is happening in our country right
now
you want your kids to learn about the
nation's founding principles and be
proud of them how about passing on
values you care about like truth freedom
responsibility hard work equality under
god if you want your kids consuming
content that actually supports your
values go to prageru right now
show your children their animated shows
books and magazines most importantly
support prageru in their efforts to take
back
america's education subscribe now don't
miss prageru's incredible
free kids content visit prageru.com
forward slash kids today
and go check them out alrighty in just
one second we'll get to the new york
city mayoral race which is an
astonishing fail in a time
where many people are claiming that
america was built on the back of
oppression the daily wire is here to
remind you the freest country in the
world was built on the back of legends
who sacrificed their own lives for the
future of the country
our new podcast america's forgotten
heroes you're gonna love it it's
fantastic it illuminates the intense
action-packed stories of southern men
who fought against all oz to save
america
during its darkest hours from john paul
jones the father of the us navy to frank
luke the 21 year old ace pilot who took
down 18 german aircraft in 18 days
during world war one
these brave men are the reason people
like me are able to voice our opinions
today
and why you're able to listen to them
subscribe now to america's forgotten
heroes on apple podcast spotify or
anywhere you listen because the first
episode does
drop tomorrow thursday july 1st and one
new action-packed episode drops every
day through the fourth of july weekend
and into next week for a total of seven
episodes too many heroes never receive
the recognition they deserve
sharing their stories with you this
independence day holiday it's our small
way of giving tribute to their heroism
if you love what you hear leave a five
star review help share these incredible
stories
thanks for listening thank you to the
heroes that made such an excellent
podcast
possible also we have so much content
here at daily wire we also
have a new documentary about clarence
thomas available at daily wire
on october 15th 1991 the united states
senate voted 52-48 to confirm
clarence thomas as the second black
american to ever sit on the highest
court
in the land if you know clarence
thomas's original story it's
unbelievable it's an
unbelievable story but all that the
media will tell you is a character
assassination campaign
about anita hill and pubic hairs on coke
cans and all the rest of that nonsense
the documentary created equal shows
clarence thomas's battle
and his ultimate triumph the documentary
is only available to daily wire members
because you'll remember amazon had it up
and then amazon quietly removed it
during black history month of all times
go to dailywear.com subscribe get 20 off
your new membership with code
justice again you're going to love it it
makes a great educational product for
your kids as well
the documentary created equal is
available to members over at
dailywire.com if you're not yet a daily
wire member
join now at dailywire.com subscribe with
codejustice for 20 off your membership
get ready for a film
unlike any other once you remember be
sure to check out all of our other great
content like our talk show candice
featuring candace owens or our first
film
run hide fight or my new series debunked
where it's a bunch left to smith's in 15
minutes or less
and get all of this and more on demand
by going to dailywire.com
subscribe check out with 20 off using
codejustice don't wait
start streaming today you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty meanwhile absolute chaos
breaking out in new york i mean it
really is
kind of an amazing thing so last night
there is this
shocking new information so the way that
new york's mayoral race works
is that there's ranked choice voting as
i've explained on the program before
basically you choose your top five
candidates
if your first candidate doesn't end up
in the top two then we actually don't
throw out your ballot
right then we go to your second choice
for the mayor
and then if your second choice doesn't
make it we move down to your third
choice for mayor so everybody's
vote gets counted but sort of in order
of preference
and the goal of ranked choice voting of
course is to mean that you don't have to
really strategically vote anymore
now instead of strategically voting you
can just kind of pick the order of your
candidate preference
and then it all comes out in the wash
i'm actually not a super giant opponent
of a ranked choice voting it just needs
to be tabulated
a lot more quickly okay so last night
there was this news that came out
where after the initial round of
balloting without counting the absentee
ballots
eric adams had been up by about nine
points in the mayor's race he had like
31 percent
compared to catherine garcia who had had
like 22 percent mia wiley was at like 21
and ryan was way down at 11 okay but
that was before they had kicked out all
of the lower ranking candidates
and then checked everybody's second
choices so last night there was
information that broke
suggesting that maya wiley was out
and that catherine garcia had closed the
gap almost entirely
right according to those results the
original results again
had this thing you know split 20
different ways
with eric adams having like 35 percent
of the vote
and then my wiley having like 26 percent
of the vote and catherine garcia having
of the vote then after the ranked choice
ballots were taken into account
maya wiley was eliminated andrew yang
was eliminated and
virtually all of those votes ended up
going to catherine garcia so suddenly it
looked like eric adams
only had 51 of the vote and catherine
garcia
had 49 percent of the vote and that was
still before we had like 120 000
outstanding ballots that yet to be
counted so it looked
very much possible that catherine garcia
could become the mayor of new york
overcoming
that lead that eric adams held in the
initial balloting that's what it looked
like okay so eric adams
then started protesting the election
you're never supposed to do this by the
way right
it's i've heard that this is very bad
that if you if you start with the stop
the steel stuff then this makes you bad
so eric adams he put out a statement he
said the vote total just released by the
board of elections is a hundred thousand
plus more than the total announced on
election night
raising serious questions we've asked
the board of elections to explain
such a massive increase and other
irregularities before we comment on the
ranked choice voting projection
we remain confident eric adams will be
the next mayor of new york because he
put together a historic five-year-old
working-class coalition of new yorkers
to make our city a safer
fairer more affordable place okay so
when this first came out people were
like
oh look at that guy doubting the results
of elections how could he do such a
thing that's uh what what a schmuck
can't believe well now it turns out that
eric adams
was right according to the new york
times quote the new york city's mayor's
race plunged into chaos on tuesday night
when the city's board of elections
released a new tally of votes in the
democratic mayoral primary
and then removed the tabulations from
his website after citing a discrepancy
the results released earlier in the day
had suggested the race between eric
adams and his two closest rivals had
tightened significantly
but just a few hours after releasing the
preliminary results the elections board
issued a cryptic tweet
revealing a discrepancy in the report
saying it was working with its technical
staff to identify where the discrepancy
occurred
by tuesday evening the tabulations had
been taken down replaced by a new
advisory that the ranked choice results
would be available starting on june 30th
then around 10 30 pm the board finally
released a statement explaining
it had failed to remove a sample remove
sample ballot images
used to test its ranked choice voting
software so basically they ran a
simulation
a few weeks ago and then they just sort
of forgot to scrub it and then
they actually added it in to their
actual vote tabulations
when the board ran the program it
counted quote both test and election
night results producing approximately
135 000 additional records
the ranked choice numbers it said would
be tabulated again
for the board of elections which has
long been plagued by dysfunction and
nepotism
this was its first try at implementing
ranked choice voting on a city-wide
scale
skeptics had expressed doubts about the
board's ability to pull off the process
that has been used successfully in other
cities the board of elections released
preliminary unofficial ranked choice
tabulations tuesday afternoon
showing adams narrowly ahead of
catherine garcia and maya wiley
eliminated
but the results may well be scrambled
again even after the board of elections
sorts through the
preliminary tally it must then count
around 124 000
democratic absentee ballots once they're
tabulated the board will then take the
new total that includes them
and run a new set of ranked choice
elimination rounds with a result not
expected until mid july so it's a
complete
absolute mess now republicans have
pointed out that
processes like giant numbers of absentee
ballots
and failures of tabulation there are
ways to stop that through
you know voter laws and then the left
has immediately declared that all of
that is deeply and horrifically racist
right in new york this is happening and
the person
who just got hurt by it is the only
serious black mayoral candidate maya
wiley's not gonna be the mayor of new
york
so that is um awkward to say the least
if this had happened in georgia
you'd hear every newspaper in the united
states talking about the innate racism
of the georgia election system instead
it's happening in new york which is just
a crap festival
and now they're like oh well you know
people make mistakes
people make mistakes maya wiley did lace
into the board of elections
she said the error was quote the result
of generations of failures that have
gone unaddressed and said sadly it is
impossible to be surprised
once again you've seen the mismanagement
that has resulted in a lack of
confidence and results
not because there is a flaw in our
election laws but because those who
implement it have failed too many times
the board of elections must now count
the remainder of the votes transparently
and ensure the integrity of the process
moving forward
she says i'm confident that every
candidate will accept the final results
and support whomever the voters have
elected
uh i i have doubts if adams ends up
losing i have some serious doubts that
uh that adams is going to accept the
results of the election instead we may
get a very trumpy adams
take on the election which would just be
the height of irony
again sophisticated new york proving
itself to be uh less than sophisticated
when it comes to actually running its
city
in pretty much every available way by
the way if it turns out that andrew yang
and garcia campaigning together ended
with yang's voters going to garcia and
thus putting her over the top against
adams
wait for the cries of racism inside the
democratic party it's just going to be
delicious
it's just going to be wonderful i am
here for it to say the very very least
so once again democrats demonstrating
that they are excellent at running
cities
and by excellence i mean absolute
horrific crap shows
on on every available level so i'm you
know
is it chardon freud yeah just a little
bit remember it was it was georgia
and arizona and and florida and all the
states that are passing new election
laws to crack down on voter fraud voter
irregularity to make people
feel safer about their elections those
are the bad guys new york is filled with
the good guys who can't perform
a simple tabulation and then idiotically
release the fake results to the general
public and have to
walk it back yeah pretty grand stuff
there from the
biggest city in the united states and
the height of sophistication
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content in
the meantime go check out the michael
mills show today he discusses the story
of nike ceo saying their brand is quote
of china and for china
yep you can hear more details over on
michael's show available right now i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover
production manager pavel wydowsky
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barber the show is
edited by adam sciovets
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 a ballot box issue throws new york
city's mayoral race into chaos
the nsa issues a non-denial denial that
it's spying on tucker
and nike's ceo describes his company as
a brand of china and for china check it
out on the michael knowles show